hi there steve kaufman here still in
london
enjoying a relaxed you know christmas
new year period with my son and his
family
um
visiting with some of their friends
and just enjoying being in london
today i want to talk about
what i would call the mind of the
language learner
and i do that because i've been reading
a book written by uh daniel willoughby
called the mind of the reader i do enjoy
i
i talk a bit from time to time about
reading reading is so important it's the
most
powerful
tool
most readily available to people to
improve
their academic success their
opportunities
in terms of professional success
and a lot of people struggle with
reading and those people who read the
best end up
doing better in life so
we should be more successful at teaching
people to read and by and large in most
countries there are a lot of people who
don't read well so there are many books
written on the subject and i tend to go
out and buy them and read them typically
i'll see them mentioned on twitter and
i'll immediately
buy them
from amazon and have them available to
read in my kindle
but then i always think of the
applications to language learning
and the important point that mr
willoughby makes and i'll leave a link
to the book here in the uh explanation
uh
box
is that it's important for reading it's
important what the attitude of the
reader is
because we can talk about techniques for
teaching reading but ultimately good
readers are people who read a lot
people who read a lot are people who
enjoy reading
how do we get people to enjoy reading
and it's kind of a virtuous circle if
you enjoy reading you read more
therefore you become a better reader
therefore you enjoy reading more and you
read more and become a better reader and
so forth and so he talks about the
self-concept of a reader
not only what motivates them initially
but they view themselves as readers and
why do they
could be any number of reasons because
if they think it's a worthwhile thing to
do because they enjoy it
they were maybe influenced by their
parents who had books around or who read
to them but it's very important to have
the self-concept of yourself as a reader
and similarly for language learning
if you think you are a language learner
if you have a positive attitude towards
language learning if you enjoy language
learning then you will do it and of
course as with reading the more you
learn languages
whether it be the one language you're
working on or even a number of languages
the more you do it the better you get
it's that simple
uh it's the old uh
katolam's formula
it was attitude plus time divided by
inhibition so if you have a positive
attitude about it about yourself as a
language learner and you put in the time
and you will if you have a good attitude
you'll do more of it
then you will get better and of course
if you have a positive attitude you'll
have fewer inhibitions
so this this idea of your self-concept
the mind of a language learner is very
important and also
as a reader i enjoy reading
i don't like being asked about what i'm
reading
i just enjoy reading if i misinterpret
something that's fine
there are people who read faster than i
do people who take speed reading courses
and can read at tremendous speeds but i
never think about that if i'm reading
i'm just enjoying what i'm reading
without worrying about whether there are
people reading faster than me or people
who are interpreting it differently and
the same with language learning i enjoy
doing it i enjoy
the occasional interaction with people
in a different language i also enjoy
learning about the cultures and the
histories and so forth and of course as
with reading the more background
information we have
the better we do
the better you know it's been
demonstrated that
if you compare people with good reading
skills and poor reading skills but the
people with poorest skills have more
background information they in fact will
understand more of what they read so
background information is important and
also of course the more we read the more
we get used to which you words are used
with which other words and we're
therefore better able to guess at
meaning i mean it's just a total
snowballing effect
so
all i'm saying is as with re where where
willoughby analyzes reading and really
comes up with no sort of magic
key to helping people read better other
than
finding ways to motivate people to read
to see themselves as readers to have a
positive self-concept as a reader and i
think the this the sort of the mind of
the reader
has analogy to language learning where
if you are a positive
language learner
you will simply do better regardless
whether other people around you might be
doing in some ways even better or
learning faster or speaking better it
doesn't matter as long as you enjoy the
process so there you have it the mind of
the language learner
bye for now
[Music]
you